i
a
brasil enfrenta el peor momento de la
pandemia con más de 2.200 muertos
diarios y un saldo anual de 273 mil
fallecidos además los expertos advierten
de que vamos camino a registrar 3.000
muertos diarios en los 27 estados
federados los hospitales públicos están
al borde del colapso hay centenas de
personas en la lista de espera y muchos
mueren precisamente a la espera de un
respirador
mientras el presidente jordi bolsonaro
parece haber cambiado de actitud está
intentando comprar vacunas en un mercado
internacional que no consigue abastecer
todos los países del mundo llega tarde
el gobierno y mientras tanto por sonar o
dice que nunca llamó la pandemia de
gripe cita lo dijo ayer en una conexión
en vivo desde sus redes sociales pero
los medios de comunicación brasileños se
han encargado de recordarle que si lo
hizo y que atacó también la vacuna
especialmente en la corona back por
venir de china
[Música]
en paraguay la crisis sanitaria por el
kobe 19 es también una crisis política
esta semana miles de manifestantes
protestaron contra el gobierno una
asunción y otros puntos del país en
medio de un record de contagio y muertes
diarias por coronavirus las
manifestaciones contra el presidente en
mario abdo benítez se iniciaron
justamente por el colapso del sistema
sanitario con una escasez de
medicamentos hospitales sin camas de
terapia disponibles y una aún deficiente
gestión en la compra de vacunas que deja
al país a la fecha con el peor registro
de vacunación contra el coronavirus en
todo el continente esta semana el
ministerio de salud pública declaró una
alerta roja sanitaria ante el aumento
acelerado de contagios mientras tanto
abdo benítez trató de desactivar el
juicio político haciendo cambios en sus
gabinetes y prometiendo aún más
instituciones por su parte la oposición
insiste en remover al primer mandatario
paraguayo y a su vicepresidente aunque
todavía no tiene los votos necesarios en
el congreso
esta semana venezuela entró de nuevo en
una radicalización de cuarentena debido
al descubrimiento reciente de la cepa
brasileña en el país según el mandatario
venezolano nicolás maduro se han
registrado casos de la nueva variante
del corona virus en el distrito capital
el estado miranda y en el estado bolívar
hasta ahora se han detectado una decena
y en un intento de controlar que se
incremente el gobierno desplegado a 16
mil brigadistas médicos para trabajar en
la detección de nuevos casos además las
autoridades venezolanas han indicado que
vacunarán con carácter prioritario en
las zonas donde se produjeron los
primeros infectados hasta el momento han
muerto dos personas diagnosticadas con
esta cepa el gobierno ha tomado algunas
medidas para detener la propagación como
limitar los actos y movilizaciones
públicas también quedan suspendidas
hasta nuevo aviso las reuniones de más
de cinco personas y reactivarán de forma
inmediata a los espacios aislamientos y
hoteles sanitarios para todos los
pacientes positivos sospechosos y
cercanos a la cadena de contacto a
venezuela han llegado a doscientas mil
vacunas desde rus y 500 miles de chinas
desde el pasado mes de febrero
[Música]